- I didn't realize how
fricking tall you are.
- I know.
It's, my wife is 5'3" so it's a strange--
- [Kelly] Oh my god, I'm 5'3".
That's why--
- [Brett] You are.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I was like,
oh my gosh, you're tall.
- [Brett] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- She, we had to go through
this whole conversation early
in the relationship where she was like,
stop bending down for the photo.
Stand up, it's okay that you're tall.
- Yeah, except I always
have this conversation
with my other short
friends that date like,
or marry tall, tall men.
Like it's gotta be awkward, you know
'cause you're...
Say kissing.
When you're stand, it's just,
are you always hunched over?
- Yeah, like unless you
wanna do that whole like
"Fifty Shades of Gray"
thing where you pick her up.
- Well, some of us can't be picked up.
(laughing)
- [Brett] Stop.
- Some of us.
I'm like, here look,
I'll climb on this stair.
- We have like baby number two on the way.
So, can or can't--
- [Kelly] Congratulations.
- Thank you.
Can or can't is not
really a thing anymore.
It's just like that's not the stage
in the relationship right now.
We're not flinging each other
around the house, you know.
- So wait, do you know
if it's a boy or girl?
- Actually, we do and we
thought it would be a fun way
to announce that.
- [Kelly] On here?
- Do the reveal right here today with you.
- Let's do it.